let's stop I think about how you
approach it okay the overwhelming number
of you and at this point in the paper I
don't think it was that bad an idea on
the only number of you drew this right
um well yours didn't look as good at
this but you know did you get the idea
you try to draw this and then you say
well look you know I from the graph you
know now that's not bad that's not bad
but you had to do more than that okay
because the thing is this entire
argument sort of falls on your graphing
exactly accurate right now who are you
to say the graph doesn't look like this
hmm now for two marks a graph was not
enough okay you need to make some
comment about why you see the critical
thing is whether this gradient right is
always above the other gradient okay now
some of you said this from your sentence
look I you write doubt this it's just a
be the X you said look it's always
positive always positive that and then
you worked out this X plus 1 they said
look it's always positive so this is
increasing and this is increasing so
that means this one's always on top of
this one really the problem with that is
because you could have taken the exact
same logic and argued it exactly the
other way around by yuko said look this
is crazy and this increasing so I just
arbitrarily pick this one I want that
one to be on top okay so that argument
didn't hold water even though a lot of
you used it okay so i thought you graph
this and then you had to make some
statement about the derivatives or let
me show you a completely different proof
which i think is a kind of elegant okay
I kind of like it ok have a look at this
this is what you are required to prove
right now part of the reason why a lot
of you stumbled over this is because you
took that and you said okay I'm just
going to run with it okay inequalities
inequalities one of the key things when
the key strategies about how to approach
inequalities is that proven a is greater
than B for any a and B sometimes it's
easy sometimes it is hard sometimes it's
obscure a much much easier
always to prove that the difference
between them is positive okay because we
know tons of things about positive
numbers right like if i can get a square
over here or if i can use calculus to do
something to this right this kind of
quality is mathematically much easier to
find right it's a lot easier to prove
conclusively so therefore in this case
the game that I would have played is
said well let's just consider and sit up
this guy I consider this okay this is
the approach i'm going to take if i
consider this I want to prove that this
thing is positive in the given domain
okay this is quite straightforward it's
quite circling all I want to do is prove
that it's positive ok so I say it what
all right I if I want to prove this
positive let's start by proving that
it's increasing right it's never going
to go down it's always going to go up ok
bun way this graph it looks something
like this roughly ok anyway you can work
that out um
I do the derivative which is very easy
derivative of this is just e to the X
minus one right so I can say wait hold
on look at this guy right for x is
greater than zero right EV x is greater
than one right that's just a fair fun so
i can say e to the X minus 1 is greater
than zero so therefore my derivative
here I should call this ever my dear
video is always positive in this domain
ok so it's increase in now that I've
established that increasing all I need
to show is that it was never below zero
right if it was always a zero and going
up because it's increasing it'll never
go below so then I prove this which
means I have proved this ok so then you
say well have a look at this graph you
can find a station in point you can say
you know the minimum the absolute
minimum of f of X in this domain right
is why of course or f of X equals zero
and it happens at zero so therefore your
rock bottom is 0 right don't forget I'm
not inclusive of the boundary so this
point is a lot of problem for me but
I've also shown that it's increasing
right it's not even like greater than
it's never going to go flat either it is
strictly increasing right must increase
sure that's it that's enough and F or F
of n is greater than zero for this
domain so that means this is greater
than zero which means that this is
greater than that and you're done ok so
always remember you can go back to
things like this they're almost always
easier to prove and by the way this is
very different from doing like left-hand
side and right hand side manipulating
them together ok I've considered
something completely separately and then
prove things about it would take me back
to what I'm required to prove